So let's discuss the solution to our Amdahl's
Law quiz. The program has 50 billion instructions.
This is how many instructions according to the
instruction count: our integer 40%, branches are 1 5th
of our instructions, stores are 10% and so
on, and this is the original CPI, and the
improvement we have is that the branches have
improved from 4 to 2 CPI. If we try
to use Amdahl's law, we might do something like this, this overall speed up
is 1 over 1 minus fraction enhanced. The fraction has its
20% so it will be 0.80 is 1 minus that plus 0.2 is
the fraction enhanced divided by this speed up is 2, so this
will be 1 over 0,9 which will be 1.111. And if you did
this, you will be horribly, horribly wrong. The reason this is wrong is that
the fraction enhanced is not as a percentage of the overall execution time
before the improvement. We said this is
how many instructions are enhanced. So branches
are 20% of the instruction count, but we don't know what percentage of execution
time was spent on branches and execution time
is what we are interested here. So that
one of the possible correct solutions here is
simply to do the following. Using the iron
law, we can compute that for 40% of our instructions we were getting a CPI of
1, for 20% of the instructions we're getting
a CPI of 4. For 30% of the instructions
we're getting a CPI of 1 and for 10% of our instructions we are getting a CPI of
3 multiply that by a 50 billion and multiply that by 1 over 2 billion which is
the 2GHz. So this would be the execution time
before the enhancement. After the enhancement, we will be
having the same thing, except there will be a
2 here, and if you do that, the answer
will be 1.24. In order to be able to use Amdahl's law, what we have to figure
out is, of this execution time, what fraction were
the branches? And if we did that, we would
be able to plug that number here and
here as the fraction enhanced and get the correct
answer here. So again, do not use something other
than the fraction of execution time as your fraction
enhanced, because you will not get the correct answer.